speaking of things that cost a lot but
are super exciting
uh page two oh crap no we'll wrap it up
this is this there's more than page two
what do you think this is
this is uh
well Louis de broiley's thesis was three
pages long and he won the Nobel Prize
for the wave particle duality so you
know size Matters in different
dimensions in life I think the the
lessons I've learned about life is the
short of the paper or the shorter the
thesis
uh actually the shorter the paper some
of the greatest papers I've ever written
are sure like I feel like uh some of the
best ideas in this world now not to
sound like a contradiction of Feynman a
contradiction on top of a contradiction
but it could be written on a napkin
honestly
um it was just kind of what tells you
something about ideas